what's the deal with airplane
peanuts from Andrew Dice Clay in the 9s
you know I got the backlash yeah you
were the first to get the backlash yeah
but yeah I was the
first to Lou CK almost a decade ago so
you take on the sense of Freedom at the
same time as you take on you know it's
been painful but I look after myself
better than I used to I think before all
this stuff happened I was quite Reckless
we've seen comedians make big time
comebacks from public cancellations
plenty of time
but what do these comeback stories
really look like some careers may never
be the same but others find power in the
freedom of being in their second Show
Business life one with more Independence
and less pressure to live up to a
standard set by people who were never
fans to begin with canel what are you
going to do cancel me no matter what you
personally think of these Comics the
fact remains they continue to tour large
venues release new specials and although
maybe no longer supported in the
mainstream they are still living life
every single day as successful comedians
and christalia is one of these examples
I got
cancelled it's now been 3 years since
Chris was canceled and last week he
released a brand new hourong special
exclusively on his website called grow
or die given that this is Chrystal
Leah's first special since releasing no
pain on Netflix back in 2020 the new
project has a lot of people talking and
with the lack of unbi interviews
featuring comedians in these shoes it
only seemed right to sit down with Chris
and ask him a few questions about the
return so Chris the title of your new
special is grow or die and while
explaining what that phrase means in the
special you mention that the truth is
they don't really want you to change
what exactly does that mean and how did
you come to this conclusion yeah I think
that we're in a uh uh like right now it
seems that uh no matter what I were to
say at this moment there are going to be
people that just to be frank like don't
want you to they want you to shut up
they want you to not speak and so you
can either do that and Fade Into
Oblivion or you have to just kind of
realize okay I'm going to have to evolve
I'm going to have to keep doing my job
and deal with that either that hate or
whatever you want to call it so that's
why I named it grow or die I felt felt
apt because there's really no other
option like no matter what I say there's
going to be people that are like nah bro
[__] you and uh so what's the
alternative I just got to keep going the
special included a few emotional moments
from audience members shouting out words
of encouragement and support during your
show over the course of your tour
leading up to this special were there
more positive moments like that and on
the flip side how do you prevent someone
who's not a fan from showing up and
disrupting your show yeah I get a lot of
uh like positive heckling you know I
people are very like at my shows very
like ride or die and like they do often
scream out like whatever it is the
positive uh Heckle and it's that's
tougher to deal with sometimes than the
other ones cuz other ones you just can
shut them down really quickly like if
it's a negative Heckle you can shut them
down down really quickly and and
everyone's on your side but if it's
positive you're like you're like oh you
got to kind of be like oh yeah thank you
but also chill because other people are
here that they paid for this but um yeah
through the tour there's been a lot of
that support which is very sweet there
hasn't been any disruptive behavior
there's been there was one guy in
Montreal I posted it on Tik Tok where he
he blew my joke like he blew it right
before I said it he said a different
joke and it messed it completely up and
I uh I almost threw him out it gets
weird you know but and then he was like
oh I'm sorry man I love you and I was
like I felt bad so I like go don't throw
him out you always judge the balance of
you know is this worth you know because
they're going to disrupt the show but
oftentimes someone will Heckle and like
only the people in the back will hear or
like only the people if you're you're up
front so only the people in the first
few rows will hear so it's like you're
like you're battling like I don't want
to mess this show up for the other
however 1500 people that are here
because 20 of them kind of heard it so
you could steamroll it but you always
kind of balancing but there haven't
there has not been any like real
disruptive [__] that's happened at my
shows but there's been a lot of support
which is great you know they're all
they're all people that showed up
because they bought tickets so and I
guess yeah heckling positive heckling
whatever in a theater is a little
different than than like I mean look at
a comedy club I think the [__] happens
more often but that's kind of the
culture in a theater people are like sat
nice they're in good seats you know
they're not folded out they're like it's
upholstery so they're not going to [__]
it so you went pretty hard in your new
special in terms of Darker jokes or edgy
language are these jokes something
you've always wanted to do throughout
your career but felt like the risk was
too high or are they more of a byproduct
of as you said in the special having
nothing to lose yeah I think I I think I
didn't consciously hold back before
this I think um but there is some sort
of like freeness to look this is going
to be something that I'm going to put
out this is going to be something that
you can get a chris.com and I don't I'm
my boss I don't have to worry about
sponsors I don't have to worry about
that stuff in that respect so there is a
sense of being able to say what whatever
I want to now that doesn't mean I'm
going to go out and try to offend people
but if something's funny and I think
it's funny and it's gonna offend people
people are gon to get offended anyway it
doesn't matter I can talk about
toothpaste and people stand up and be
like that's not cool my aunt use that
toothpaste or whatever it is but like uh
yeah so I people get offended anyway and
then also I don't have to worry about it
now because I'm [__] free dude I feel
like it I feel like once you cross over
to the uh the big corporations aren't
going to deal with you there is a sense
of freeness in it because you can say
whatever you want um and yeah you got
nothing to lose which is which is a
positive thing if you make it a positive
thing and understand what you're saying
about like you're releasing this on your
own website so you don't have to deal
with those sponsors which is nice but
how does working out these kind of jokes
like the game show joke go over in your
home base of La crowds yeah um yeah
that's a particularly that joke was a
particularly so I I was doing that joke
in La it was working fine and on the
road it was working it was F working
fine and then I had Portland on the
books and I was like okay if this is
going to be a problem it's gonna be a
problem here yeah you know what I'm
saying they got people who just like
show their [__] to cops I'm saying yeah
like in protest and the cops are just
like Ah that's that's bother us that
much but we so I was like I'm going to
do it in Portland and this will be the
real test and I realized something early
on in my in my career it was still true
to to my point in this Portland show if
you have like a place that's known for
something a city that's known for
certain thing like Portland is known to
be woke right right y they will make it
a point to prove to you they're not that
way oh that makes sense it's a crazy
weird thing it's like when you say if
you if I say you guys aren you're not
going to get this joke it makes you
think like no I'm gonna get it and it
makes you want to get it it's like that
kind of a thing they're fighting against
this Narrative of we're woke and then
and when I did that joke there it
probably it definitely hit harder than
it does so I was like man that's so
interesting you know because they were
already they look I say some Choice
words in that bit and it's only because
I think it worked in the bit and it's
funny in in other spots in the in in
America they're already saying that [__]
freely so they this is not a surprise to
them yeah but in Portland it's like oh
this guy isn't worried about us getting
mad at him in a way it becomes sort of
the safe Zone that makes sense that's
really cool I never thought I suppose
some people might still be offended I
mean they are going to be but uh but
yeah I've noticed that in those
particular areas it's interesting well
we we've seen comedians get cancelled
and make big comebacks before one of the
most famous examples being Louis CK who
was early to releasing specials on his
own website for a onetime fee and was
hugely successful obviously you don't
need to reveal any specifics but has the
release or grow or die been a positive
experience for you overall and can we
expect more crystalia specials to be
released this way so it's been you know
it's very nerve-wracking to do it
because you don't [__] know like you
don't know what's going to happen you
don't know how people are going to go to
your website like websites were
something that existed in 2003 and then
everyone's like oh wait hold on there's
we don't need those we have Instagram so
it's like it was nerve-wracking and it
it's it's a huge relief now like I did
not know I'm I'm pleasantly surprised
and I can only imagine doing this from
now on but who knows if I I think I
would do my next one on on on on my own
it's just I would implore I know I'm at
a certain level so obviously I can't say
like more artists should do this because
it might not be beneficial to somebody
who's hasn't quote unquote made it or
whatever it is but man some of these
people that are releasing stuff on
Netflix and some of these people that
are releasing stuff on like Amazon and
Hulu they should be releasing it on
their own I am telling you it's awesome
and people will show up they do
appreciate you they will pay for it yeah
it's it's great and it's still happening
I released it I don't know six days ago
and it just keeps growing and growing
and people will just keep buying it it's
it's just the way to do it I think it
eventually it will be the way to do it
but yeah I'm I'm pleasantly surprised
and I'm very happy and very relieved
your oldest son Calvin got a lot of
shine during the special uh and it's got
to be cool for him to have his dad
capture all these early stories and
moments from his life in an hourong
comedy special that he can watch back
one day do you feel like your newest son
William will ever get jealous when he
sees this special for the first time
yeah I think I would but I gota I I mean
if you know what I mean if my dad was
doing stand up and it was none about me
and only about Matt my brother I'd be
like Dad what the [__] but you know he's
six he can't talk yet we'll see if he
grows up and gets jealous I I got some
stuff about him already now that I'm
doing so uh but yeah I don't know
something about that first kid and the
wow of it and the the funniness of it
and the observations that come when you
first have a child is uh that's going to
be tough to beat but if he gets jealous
I will say this I will if if if William
grows up to be like yo you didn't do
enough material about me I will do I
will straight up roast him on on on the
next one yeah as long as I have his
Blessing are you gonna get a William
tattoo also I have a Calvin I have one
for that is for Calvin and uh which is
the Triceratops and yes I do want to get
the uh one for William but I have to
know what he likes yet he's still only 6
months and so far the only thing I know
he likes is milk yeah well Chris thank
you so much for joining the show today I
appreciate your time and you can go find
his new special grow or die at
crystal.com yeah go enjoy appreciate you
guest spots from last week The Joe Rogan
Experience talked with Whitney Cummings
Tim Dylan was on a bone to pick Matt and
Shane secret podcast was Shane Lis J
Gomez and Marlon Vera John Stamos was
the guest on Whiskey Ginger flagrant
talked with Jason Williams two bears one
cave was Bert and steo killed Tony this
week was with Ron White and Paulie Shore
taste buds battled Italian vers Jewish
delies with Lou cats and Ian fance y m
talked with ESO of zarf face hun Kim was
on first date we might be drunk was with
Jim Jeff car top was on the blocks
podcast Miss Pat was on are you garbage
and Christa Stephano was the guest on
bertcast I I've got a full body scan
where you do the lungs and the all the
organs and and like uh they found a lump
on my kidney and I was like and I was
freaked out and they're like oh it's
it's I think you've had it your whole
life it's been there we've noticed it
before but it's a bottle cap
yeah but they but do you how fast do you
drink I don't know man this past weekend
with theovon was a solo episode same
with the Tim Dylan show steveo was on
the Adam friedin Show podcast the
Workaholics were on tiger belly Colin
Quinn was on hey babe Jordan Jensen and
Sarah Kubrick were on take your shoes
off Being Ian with Jordan welcome TJ
Miller TJ Miller and Ian fance were on
you know what dude Trevor Wallace went
on Chrissy chaos Sydney Washington
visited stav's world the honeydude
talked with Britney Schmidt and there's
a new episode of the regs as far as
brand new standup comedy specials are
either out right now or coming out soon
Ralph Barbosa cabanga is out right now
on Netflix Dusty slay released a
hilarious full 52 minutes set on YouTube
and also out on YouTube Matteo Lane the
advice special part two has been
uploaded to his channel along with Mike
fy's new 20-minute Special A Night at
the comedy cell which is out right now
along with the interview we did with
Mike for this channel that came out over
the weekend so be sure to check that
video out on the end screen right after
this and a few specials in the works
right now they'll be coming out soon
Jessica kerson has a brand new crowdwork
special set to hit YouTube any day now
in fact it might be live by the time you
see this video also stavos has a new
special coming to Netflix December 5th
titled fat Rascal more specials coming
to Netflix soon Matt R natural selection
will be premiering November 15th and
Trevor Wallace pterodactyl will be
coming to Amazon Prime on November 14th
please be sure to subscribe right now to
stay in the comedy loop I hope you
enjoyed today's video arguably our
highest profile interview yet on the
comedy news which obviously would not be
possible without all of you watching
this video so thank you so much for
watching and if you're interested in
claiming your free joke World stickers
check out the links in the description
below thanks
again joke
world and it world is
wld
that's a great uh YouTube channel joke
World check it out